hey
what's happening here
[Music]
i can help what's wrong
hurry they're coming through the window
run that's over now you're here with me
[Music]
their minds are lost in a thousand hells
who did this
mongol tracks
what do they do to these people
this color
i don't recognize the tribe
some kind of restraint on her she bit
her tongue off
blood to death what did these people
endure
[Music]
looks like an altar
for some kind of mongol ceremony
ego calls to you
he's chanting
filling them with bloodlust
more of them
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
bastards
you won't torment anyone else
i need to find out who these invaders
are
tell me what you did to these people
they heard the core of the eagle
the eagle
is here leader
she
will lead the eagle tribe to your shores
with all of ikki island at her back
they came from iki island
help me
may your death benefit all beings
[Music]
um
i came as soon as i heard
those people
they're getting the help they need
but i don't know if they will recover
what happened to them
i'm not sure
i haven't seen these mongols before
they claim to follow someone called the
eagle
and they're planning an attack on
tsushima those people lost their minds
if the eagle can do that to the whole
island
she won't
how will you find her
one of our people mentioned iki island
it's full of raiders and criminals
they hate the samurai
i know
my father led the campaign to pacify
them and he
he died on that island
the samurai retreated after he fell
now something monstrous has taken root
on ikky island
i have to go back
is not welcome on iki island if i want
to wear the sakayama there
i need to conceal the clan markings
no
your boat's ready
we sail on your command
are you sure about this lord sakai
iki island's no place for a samurai
my father built it to last
if there's trouble on iki
the locals may be sheltering there i'll
get you there as fast as i can my lord
the sea's been angry ever since those
mongols arrived
storms are especially fierce around iki
not surprising
the eagle tribe is doing something
horrible there whatever they're up to
they've angered the kami but don't worry
i've sailed through worse come kagey
[Music]
brace yourself boy
crockett
okay
i hope you made it ashore
did i make it
[Music]
looks like an old smuggling hideout
i need to find a way out
hmm it worked
[Music]
you